Ja, Wissenschaftler machen
Tierversuche aus Jux und Tollerei.
Einfach,
weil es so billig und bequem ist.
* Titelmusik *
Freunde der Sonne, das heute
ist ein eher spontanes Video.
Auch wenn das Thema eins ist,
das ich schon lange behandeln wollte.
Nämlich Tierversuche
in der biomedizinischen Forschung.
Denn ich weiß, dass auch ihr euch
sehr für dieses Thema interessiert.
Letzte Woche hat CollegeHumor
ein Video hochgeladen mit dem Titel
"The Problem with Lab Mice",
das Problem mit Labormäusen.
Es ist Teil des Formats
"Adam Ruins Everything".
Adam Conover,
der Moderator oder Protagonist
deckt in "Adam Ruins Everything"
weitverbreitete Irrtümer auf.
Die Videos sind sehr gut produziert,
kurz, knackig, unterhaltsam
und sammeln über die Monate
ein paar Millionen Views.
Ich möchte das neueste Video
von "Adam Ruins Everything"
über Tierversuche nutzen,
um ein erstes Reaction Video
zu machen. Yep.
Das CollegeHumor Video hab ich euch
natürlich unten verlinkt.
Ihr könnt es euch anschauen.
Es ist auf Englisch.
"Adam Ruins Everything"
ist immer so sketchartig aufgebaut.
Im Laufe des Videos
überzeugt Adam sein Gegenüber,
sich von einem langgeglaubten oder
verbreiteten Irrtum zu verabschieden.
Sein Gegenüber in diesem Video
ist eine junge Forscherin.
Diese junge Forscherin spricht
den Kernirrtum dieser Folge aus:
What? Everyone knows testing
on rodents is practically the same
as doing actual human trials.
"Jeder weiß, dass Experimente
mit Mäusen oder Nagetieren
praktisch dasselbe sind
wie klinische Tests an Menschen."
First of all: es gibt keinen
Wissenschaftler auf dem Planeten,
der glaubt, dass Mausexperimente
gleichzusetzen wären
mit Experimenten an Menschen.
Ich weiß nicht mal,
ob es einen Nicht-Wissenschaftler
gibt, der das glaubt.
Die Folge fängt schon mal damit an,
dass die "common misconception",
der weitverbreitete Irrtum,
völlig übertrieben dargestellt wird,
was ich von vornherein schade finde.
Ich finds einfach schädlich,
auch nur zu suggerieren,
dass Wissenschaftler im Labor,
seien sie
noch so jung und unerfahren,
nicht wüssten,
warum sie mit Mäusen arbeiten.
Wir haben genug Probleme
mit Misstrauen in die Wissenschaft.
So fangen sie an.
Okay, machen wir weiter.
Adam erklärt,
dass 95 % der Versuchstiere
in der biomedizinischen Forschung
Mäuse sind.
Dann fährt er fort,
Mäuse seien allerdings
denkbar schlechte Versuchstiere,
denn über 80 % der Versuche,
die an Mäusen funktionieren,
funktionieren in Menschen nicht mehr.
Das wird visualisiert
mit diesem Geld-Shreddern.
Die Entwicklungskosten für neue
Medikamente wären dadurch sehr hoch.
D.h. weniger neue Medikamente
oder Medikamente,
die wir uns leisten können.
Wir nehmen noch einen Fakt hinzu,
der im Video angesprochen wird.
Dass Mäuse zwar zu 97 %
dieselbe DNA haben wie Menschen,
aber diese 3 % Unterschied
machen einen großen Unterschied.
Physiologisch.
Fassen wir erst mal zusammen,
was bisher gesagt wurde:
Die meisten biomedizinischen Versuche
werden an Mäusen gemacht.
Ja, das stimmt.
Nur ein Teil
der vorklinischen Studien
lassen sich auch auf die klinischen
Studien mit den Menschen übertragen.
Ja, auch das stimmt leider.
Die Entwicklungskosten für
Medikamente sind erschreckend hoch.
Auch das stimmt leider.
Und all das ist ein Problem.
Auch das stimmt.
Machen wir weiter mit dem
problematischen Teil dieses Videos.
Die junge Forscherin ist entsetzt
über die neuen Erkenntnisse.
Sie fragt sich: warum machen wir dann
so viele Mausversuche,
wenn die doch so problematisch sind?
Hier kommt Adams Antwort:
Because they're cheap and convenient.
Ich störe mich schon direkt
an dem Wort "convenient".
Das heißt ja so viel
wie praktisch oder geeignet.
Aber es heißt auch so viel
wie bequem, angenehm.
Das Ganze impliziert, dass Forscher
"out of convenience",
"out of sheer convenience",
Methoden bevorzugen,
das ist natürlich Quatsch.
Es geht nicht um Convenience,
sondern viel mehr um Suitability
und Feasibility.
Also wie geeignet
sind diese Methoden und Modelle,
und können wir das umsetzen?
Inwieweit können wir das umsetzen
mit den Resourcen, die wir haben
in einem bestimmten Labor.
Der unschöne Nebengeschmack,
der durch "Convenience" mitschwingt,
festigt sich
im folgenden Teil von dem Video.
Adam fährt nämlich fort zu erklären,
dass Mäuse,
im Vergleich zu anderen
Versuchstieren, ein Schnäppchen sind.
Der Fakt stimmt, was mich stört ist,
dass zu keiner Zeit erwähnt wird,
wie teuer Tierversuche
an sich eigentlich sind.
Wenn wir von "Convenience" sprechen,
sind Zellversuche in Petrischalen
viel mehr "Convenience".
Zellen zu züchten
ist viel weniger Aufwand,
als Tiere zu züchten,
die Modelle zu entwickeln,
die Tiere zu halten, zu pflegen,
die Räumlichkeiten dafür zu haben.
Okay, Adams zweiter Punkt
geht mehr auf die "Convenience" ein.
Er sagt, dass Mäuse sehr leicht
genetisch modizifierbar sind.
Ja, Mäuse ohne Immunsysteme.
Mäuse, die im Dunkeln leuchten,
Mäuse mit Extratumoren. Das stimmt.
Ich krieg hier so 'nen leichten
Mad-Scientist-Frankenstein-Vibe.
Ich muss sagen, es ist abartig.
Ja, es ist abartig,
dass wir Mäusen Tumore verpassen.
Die Frage ist nur,
wenn ich keine Tumormaus habe,
wie will ich einen Tumor untersuchen,
wenn nicht in einem Tier oder Mensch?
Ich finde, dass sich die Sendung hier
fast schon ein bisschen widerspricht.
Weil am Anfang
wurde uns noch erklärt,
dass Mäuse
denkbar schlechte Modelle sind,
weil sie so wenig
mit Menschen zu tun haben.
Hier wird jetzt
als Absurdität dargestellt,
in welchen Farben, Formen,
genetischen Veränderungen
Mäuse daherkommen.
Dabei ist das genau der Grund,
warum Mäuse so wichtige Modelle sind.
Eben weil man sie genetisch
so variieren kann.
Eben weil es Mäuse gibt
ohne Immunsystem,
wo man Immunkrankheiten testen kann.
Diese Abartigkeit
ist ja gleichzeitig auch das,
wo das medizinische Potenzial liegt.
Dieses Mad-Scientist-Frankenstein-
Bild wird jetzt weitergesponnen.
Adam erwähnt nämlich als Nächstes
den Animal Welfare Act.
Das ist ein Gesetz, das in den USA
1966 verabschiedet wurde.
Um Tiere zu schützen
im Bereich Research und Exhibition.
Labormäuse und Laborratten sind von
diesem Tierschutzgesetz ausgenommen.
Das klingt jetzt erst mal
ziemlich grausam.
Unterstrichen wird das
von einer Maus,
die
auf einem Mini-Elektrostuhl sitzt.
Und die Forscherin sagt dazu:
"Oh yeah, we could never
get away with this on a rabbit."
Wissenschaftler hier so kaltblütig
und grausam darzustellen
ist prinzipiell problematisch.
Zweitens impliziert das Ganze hier,
dass Forscher mit Labormäusen
so grausam umgehen können,
wie sie wollen,
ohne Konsequenzen davonzutragen.
Ohne dass sich jemand darum schert,
wie es den Tieren geht.
Und das stimmt nicht.
Nur weil in den USA Labormäuse nicht
unter den Animal Welfare Act fallen,
heißt das nicht, dass sie
unreguliert sind, im Gegenteil.
Tierversuche
werden extrem streng reguliert.
Jede Tierversuchsreihe
muss individuell beantragt werden.
Und jeder Antrag wird
von einer Kommission begutachtet.
Und über jedem individuellen Versuch
stehen Leitlinien.
Die sogenannten "3 Rs",
Replace, Reduce und Refine.
Zu Deutsch:
Vermeiden, verringern, verbessern.
Das sind die Leitlinien.
Die Wissenschaftler
sind verpflichtet,
Tierversuche, wo möglich,
zu vermeiden und zu verringern.
Außerdem sind die Wissenschaftler
dazu verpflichtet,
"Refine",
ihre Experimente so zu verbessern,
dass die Tiere
möglichst wenig leiden,
z. B. möglichst wenig Schmerzen
erleiden oder anders leiden.
Natürlich gibt es auch
externe Einrichtungen,
welche die Forschungseinrichtungen
da überprüfen.
Sie schauen ihnen auf die Finger,
ob alles richtig gemacht wird.
Übrigens, weil mich das auch immer
sehr viele Leute fragen,
ob Tierversuche auch
in Kosmetikartikeln getestet werden.
Seit März 2013 kann man europaweit
keine Kosmetikartikel mehr kaufen,
die an Tieren getestet wurden.
Das ist ein Verbot.
Und natürlich ist auch das Testen
an Tieren ebenso verboten.
Zurück zur Forschung.
Die Frage ist doch,
wenn wir keine Tumormäuse hätten,
was ist die Alternative,
um Krebs zu untersuchen?
Hier kommen wir so langsam zum
grundlegenden Problem dieses Videos.
Adam holt eine Expertin dazu.
Prof. Dr. Azra Raza.
Sie forscht an Leukämie, sie spricht
sich öffentlich dagegen aus,
dass die biomedizinische Forschung
so auf Mausmodelle fokussiert ist.
Völlig in Ordnung, das so zu sehen.
Nur, was sie in diesem Video
als Alternative vorschlägt,
ist mehr als mau.
Sie sagt,
anstatt Mausversuche zu machen,
sollte man sich auf die Untersuchung
menschlicher Krebszellen
konzentrieren.
Erstens wird das natürlich gemacht.
Natürlich untersucht man
menschliche Krebszellen.
Diese Experimente
nennt man In-Vitro-Experimente.
lso im Reagenzglas.
In fast allen biomedizinischen
Studien gibt es sowohl In-Vitro-,
als auch In-Vivo-Daten, das sind dann
Experimente am lebenden Organismus.
Meistens Mäuse.
Jedes Modell
hat so seine Vor- und Nachteile.
Natürlich, während menschliche
Krebszellen schon menschlich sind,
verhalten sich ein paar Krebszellen
im Labor natürlich...
natürlich anders als ein Tumor
in einem lebenden Organismus,
in einem menschlichen Körper.
Natürlich kann ich nicht die Folgen,
die ein Anti-Tumor-Medikament
auf meinen ganzen Körper hat,
anhand von ein paar Tumorzellen
oder ein bisschen Tumorgewebe
in meiner Petrischale festmachen.
Das ist völlig klar.
Und genauso ist es klar,
nämlich, wie gesagt,
jedem Wissenschaftler klar,
dass eine Maus nicht dasselbe ist
wie ein Mensch.
Es gibt ja auch "humanized mice",
also Mäuse,
denen menschliche Zellen
oder Gene eingesetzt wurden.
Damit sie eher
einem menschlichen Organismus ähneln.
Und selbst diese Mäuse,
das weiß jeder,
können niemals klinische Studien
oder Tests an Menschen ersetzen.
Diese ganzen In-Vitro-Tests,
Computersimulationen,
alle Methoden, die es gibt,
jede für sich, genauso
wie der Mausversuch selbst,
alles sind nur Modelle.
Die ihre Grenzen haben.
Ich weiß ja selbst als Chemikerin,
Computersimulationen
sind der heiße Shit in der Chemie.
Also der Versuch,
Reaktionsmechanismen
durch Berechnungen vorauszusagen,
sodass man nicht mehr
alles ausprobieren muss.
Das würde auch sehr viel Geld sparen.
Selbst das, selbst eine Reaktion
zwischen zwei Molekülen,
oder zwischen einem Molekül
und einem Protein,
sind so kompliziert zu modellieren.
Geschweige denn ein ganzer fucking
Organismus mit allem was dazugehört.
Das sind wir noch sehr,
sehr, sehr weit von entfernt.
Diese Methoden kann man kombinieren,
die können sich ergänzen.
Damit wir so etwas Komplexes wie
einen Tumor in einem Organismus
hinreichend beschreiben können.
Nur zu behaupten,
dass Wissenschaftler Mäuse töten,
weil es so billig und convenient ist,
obwohl es mit menschlichen Krebs-
zellen genauso gut oder besser ginge,
das stimmt einfach nicht.
Also die Probleme
in der Medikamentenentwicklung
wurden in diesem Video
eigentlich schon ganz gut benannt.
Ich finds nur schade, wie die
Fakten hier interpretiert wurden.
Man sieht hier ganz schön,
dass es in der Wissenschaft
nie nur um die Fakten alleine geht.
Es geht immer, immer um den Kontext.
Und darum,
wie wir die Fakten interpretieren.
Selbst die Quellen,
die in diesem Video genannt werden,
und es werden hier
einige Quellen zitiert,
sind meiner Meinung nach
teilweise falsch zitiert.
Weil vielleicht einzelne Fakten
aus der Quelle rausgenommen werden,
aber nicht die Hauptmessage
dieser Quelle.
Zum Beispiel wurde ein Kommentar-
Artikel von Steve Parren zitiert,
der 2014 in "Nature" erschien.
In diesem Kommentar
geht es aber gar nicht darum,
dass Mausversuche Quatsch sind.
Der Autor kritisiert stattdessen,
das allgemeine Experimentendesign
der vorklinischen Studien.
Also kurz gesagt:
Die Mausversuche
müssen besser werden.
Nicht abgeschafft werden, besser.
Die Probleme des Ganzen
sind völlig klar.
Die Erfolgsrate
von der Entwicklung eines Medikaments
im Labor,
von der chemischen Synthese
bis hin zur Anwendung im Patienten,
die Erfolgsrate ist viel zu klein.
Erschreckend klein.
Die Zeit, die die Entwicklung dauert,
ist erschreckend lang.
Und die Kosten, die da reingehen,
sind erschreckend groß.
Aber eins ist Fakt:
wenn wir Tierversuche
jetzt hier rausnehmen würden,
dann wären die Erfolgsraten
noch kleiner.
Es würden mehr Menschen
zu Schaden kommen.
Und es wäre noch teurer.
Denn die klinischen Studien
sind das, was richtig teuer ist.
Es ist ethisch total vertretbar,
wenn man sagt,
alle Leben dieser Welt
haben für mich denselben Wert.
Ein Mäuseleben hat genau
so viel Wert wie ein Affenleben,
genau so viel wie ein Menschenleben.
Wenn ich davon überzeugt bin
und sage,
wenn wir Medikamente
für Menschen entwickeln,
sollten wir sie auch
an Menschen testen,
ist das eine konsequente,
logische Denkweise.
Ich vertrete eine andere Meinung,
die Meinung,
dass Tierversuche
das kleinere Übel sind.
Mit dem Ziel,
Menschenleben zu retten.
Jetzt erst mal danke,
dass ihr das Video geschaut hat.
Ich habe auch nur die Oberfläche
des Problems ankratzen können
in diesem Video.
Lasst uns weiter offen
darüber diskutieren.
Wir sind hier, um Dinge zu verstehen,
nicht um uns gegenseitig
die Köpfe einzuschlagen.
Schreibt Fragen und Anmerkungen
in die Kommentare.
Ich werde sie lesen und versuchen,
hier und da auch mal zu antworten.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)